hello welcome to the Detroit experience
I'm an Android and I'll be your hostess
you are now ready to begin Detroit
remember this is not just a story this
is our future
[Music]
I'm Callie reading for reviewer Peter
Brown Detroit become human posits a
well-worn future when androids have
become so lifelike and so deeply
integrated into human society that
surely it's only a matter of time and
circumstance until they achieve
consciousness there isn't much time
spent examining how that might be
possible
Detroit is primarily focused on androids
experiences during the process of their
awakening and they're shocked when
looking at humanity with eyes unclouded
for the first time ultimately it's up to
you to decide how they react in the face
of adversity
I want you to leave Alice alone there's
a gameplay light experience broken up
into dozens of chapters with hundreds of
decisions to make during cutscenes and
explorative sequences pivotal moments
gone awry can lead some characters to
premature deaths but even small
deviations can have a lasting impact
many of the decisions may seem mundane
at first but however benign a choice may
seem they add up and gradually draw you
into each character's individual
experience Detroit is purposefully
designed in a disorderly fashion leaving
you with many cliffhangers throughout
the game as it cycles from one
character's perspective to the next at
the end of every ten to twenty minute
chapter the main characters cara connor
and marcus each bring something
different to the table and that variety
ensures you're never bored and almost
always surprised by what happens next
Cara a housekeeper Android belonging to
an abusive drug addled single father
becomes a guardian on the run protecting
Alice the little girl she watches over
the fact that danger for Cara also means
danger for a young child significantly
raises the stakes you strive to protect
them from the worst examples of humanity
gone astray and though it's easy to
identify the right choices to ensure
their safety getaways are often messy
[Music]
by comparison Connors chapters are more
personal and inquisitive he assists a
worn out detective named Hank who
loathes his presence due to a
deep-seated prejudice and the two must
work together to solve a series of
murders tied to rogue Androids where
Cara's owner is OneNote and unbelievably
harsh Hank can be swayed to trust you
over time and overcome his cynicism it's
not always easy to know what will
convince him of your worth but Hank
knows better than to listen to someone
who only tells him what he wants to hear
somewhat Syrian you call it a blue blood
it's the fluid that powers androids bio
components
it evaporates after a few hours and
becomes invisible to the naked eye but I
bet you can still see it can't you
correct
Hank and Connor will regularly
investigate crime scenes together where
you're required to analyze your
environment gather clues and recreate
events by interpolating evidence not
every crime scene tells a compelling
story but the process of investigation
is consistently engaging Connors
allegiance to humans and his first-hand
experience is dealing with Hanks blunt
hatred give you a chance to better
understand both sides of detroit's
embroiled society if there's one Android
in Detroit who deserves his own story to
be blown up and given more screen time
it's Connor the most pivotal character
of a lot is Marcus and while he is
involved with some of Detroit's most
creative scenes he is remarkably lacking
in nuance at the start he has the most
fortunate existence his owner is a kind
elderly painter who encourages free
thought and treats Marcus as though he
was his own son meanwhile the painters
actual son is a complete jerk who runs
the risk of ruining his father's and
Marcus's well-being this inevitably
comes to pass and it's from here that
Detroit's big picture plot kicks off the
fight for Android equality who are you
fugitives just like you the discussion
is a valid one to have given the context
at hand but the way that the social
disparity between humans and androids is
conveyed in Detroit is such an on the
nose series of references to the
American civil rights movement that it's
hard not to be taken aback androids are
forced into the back of buses segregated
from some public areas and private
establishments and made to use the
stairs instead of escalators for some
reason when Marcus rallies other
rebellious Androids and you get to pick
their protest slogan you are actually
given the option to choose we have a
dream these references are distracting
and at no point does it feel justified
to lift from the history of actual
people who've suffered and continued to
suffer in the real world I came to
Jericho because here androids are free
free to live in the dark hoping that no
one finds us free to die in silence
waiting for a change it's never gonna
come these moments are unforgettably
lame but at the testament to the story
strengths elsewhere that they don't
completely drag the experience down as a
whole
yes I have a gun Jack Detroit excels at
presenting dire situations danger seems
to lurk around every corner and because
you are expected to react quickly under
stress you can't help but feel anxious
when either Cara or Markus are at risk
of being discovered by humans after
going rogue
sometimes one misstep is all it takes to
upend an otherwise peaceful chapter and
you don't want to feel responsible for
triggering a chaotic turn of events
Detroit wouldn't be so effective at
bringing you into its world if not for
its overall stellar presentation some
NPCs and secondary characters do stand
out due to below average production
values but it's only because most
characters and scenes are so beautifully
rendered even if Detroit stumbles on a
semi-regular basis it is almost always
captivating to behold
at the end of each chapter as well as in
the pause menu Detroit presents you with
an explicit breakdown of the choices
you've made this is position as a
feature one that allows you to reflect
on your actions and if you so choose to
immediately go back and make different
decisions but in effect this feedback
methodology is ultimately detrimental
destroying your immersion by reminding
you of the game you're playing and
reducing your influence to a point score
that can be traded in for unlockable
character models and documentaries
there's no way to disable these
flowcharts and I really wish there was
[Music]
these unavoidable flowcharts like the
blatant and cheap appropriation of
American history dragged down Detroit's
otherwise gripping tale
despite being built for multiple
playthroughs it's difficult to imagine
jumping back into fix mistakes or
exhaust every possible outcome for the
sake of completion ISM things didn't
always go the way I wanted but that was
a burden I chose to bear and the story
benefited from my commitment Detroit has
the makings of a truly memorable game
and in many ways pieces of it will stick
with me for a long time it is too
beautiful too haunting and too
impressive to forget
[Music]